hey what's up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to the definitive video to send
your friends to on facebook twitter or
google plus of the new google chrome
beta for android so this is as of today
the newest release of a browser on
android from google itself we'll go
ahead and open it up and take a look at
it for the first time as yes it was
released today if anything is the most
compelling reason to use chrome on the
desktop you know it's a fast browser
it's a secure browser and it's coming to
mobile here and you'll see there has
been a few interesting changes right off
the bat there are some user interface
changes first of all there's some really
weird tab switching on going on here so
first of all i can swipe to the right to
go to my next tab which is pretty sweet
here you can see i have facebook open i
have google plus open and i have a
google.com tab here i also have a
settings tab what i can also do is hit
that multiple tabs button here and
you'll see i have this interesting
accelerometer controlled way of flipping
through my tabs
and revealing what tabs i have open so i
can go straight to facebook straight to
google plus
and just flip around between the tabs
here which is kind of interesting and i
like it in this tab mute view you can
also exit a tab here or just swipe it
out and never have to look at it again
you can also open new tabs of course
to view other stuff but if there's any
really compelling reason to use chrome
and i'm serious about this because it's
finally come to
mobile is the settings there are some
pretty crazy stuff going on in here so
i'll show you
when you're signed into chrome as you
probably are on your desktop you have
your google account hooked up and
that'll be able to sync all your
bookmarks all your history and all sorts
of settings and things like that to your
phone second of all is auto sign in
which we would expect so if you're
signed into facebook on your uh desktop
site and you don't want to have to
remember that password this will
remember the password as well as soon as
you sign in and if you're not a fan of
that crazy tilt scrolling you can
disable it in developer tools the single
most important version and this is just
on the phone of the settings is the
other devices button
and i'll go ahead and show you right now
this is the transformer prime tf201 in
the background and it's letting me know
that two minutes ago i had google plus
open so i can go ahead and write open
google plus that was open on the
transformer prime without any sort of
delay because it knows that's what's
open on the transformer prime but there
are some other things that are different
on the tablet so let's go ahead and
switch over to tablet view and check out
what's different there so now we're here
on the tablet and you can see that first
of all the nexus was right i do have
google plus open here on the tablet and
if you want any further proof we'll go
to other devices here and it'll tell us
what the galaxy nexus is running and
sure enough is google plus and the new
tab page and that's totally correct but
what you'll notice is also interesting
is this is showing the mobile version of
the website and that's because as of
right now there is no request desktop
site option as there was in the stock
browser so that's one of the cons and
the other con which i'll go ahead and
get out the way right now is that adobe
flash is not supported so if you were
hoping to be able to use
your desktop sites that were full of
adobe flash stuff that's not going to
work right off the bat at least right
now in google chrome for android if
you're okay with all the rest of that
and you like the tab switching google
chrome actually looks like a bit of a
desktop browser when you're using it on
your tablet you can see it looks it kind
of resembles chrome for mac actually i
can say that because i use chrome for
mac now and it looks very very similar
to that
also if we go back into our settings
here again you'll find the same sort of
settings here you can sign into your
google account and sync everything like
your bookmarks history everything is the
same and it does resemble a desktop
experience so i would say if anyone is
looking forward to using uh such a very
high-end tablet you should go with a
high-end browser and so far google
chrome has looked to be like that either
way this has been mkbhd with a quick
video google chrome beta for android 4.0
and above devices so i'll keep you
updated if this is updated to a later
version or if this changes significantly
either way this has been mkbhd thanks
for watching and i'll talk to you guys
in the next one
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you